let's say that x is equal to five if we
assume that x is equal to five what
would be the value of three
times x
three times x
plus one
three times x plus 1. and i'll give you
a second to think about that
well to evaluate this when x is equal to
5 everywhere you see an x you just need
to substitute that with a 5. so 3 times
x plus 1 is going to be the same thing
as three times five three i'll write
this way three times five notice where i
saw an x before i've replaced it with a
five three times five
plus one well three times 5 is going to
be equal to 15 and then i have the plus
1 right over here so 15 plus 1 is equal
to 16. so this expression 3x plus 1 when
x is equal to 5 evaluates to
16. now what if we had a different value
for x what would this expression
evaluate to if x
if x were equal to
negative 2. so once again what is the
value of 3 times x
three times x plus one
three times x plus one when x is equal
to negative two and once again i'll give
you a little bit of time to think about
what this expression is given this value
of x
once again we just substitute where we
see an x we replace it with a negative
two so three x plus one is going to be
the same thing as three instead instead
of an x we have put a negative 2 in
there 3 times negative 2
3 times negative 2
plus 1. i'm doing that same purple color
3 times negative 2 plus 1 is going to be
equal to three times negative two is
negative six
so this part right over here is negative
six and then we have plus one negative
six plus one is equal to negative five
so when x is equal to negative two three
3x plus 1 is equal to
negative 5. let's do another one let's
say and just to show you that the
variable doesn't always have to be x it
really can just be any symbol just so
that you can keep track of it what would
be the value of the expression a squared
minus a
when a is equal to
when a is equal to
6. once again i'll give you a little bit
of time to think about with this when a
is equal to 6 what is a squared
minus a
well everywhere you see an a you just
replace it with a 6. so this is going to
be the same so i'm going to put the 6 in
yellow so this is going to be the same
thing as 6
6 squared
minus 6. everywhere where i saw an a
i've replaced it with a 6. so what is 6
squared 6 squared is 36
so this part right over here evaluates
to 36 and then i have the minus and then
i'm going from that i'm going to
subtract 6. so 36 minus 6 well that just
evaluates out to
30. so when a is equal to 6 a squared
minus a is equal to
is equal to 30.